and finally new rule you can't yell at
someone for breaking a rule you just
made up
scientists yes scientists are generally
pretty liberal have been naming diseases
after the places they came from for a
very long time Zika is from the Zika
forest Ebola from the Ebola River
hantavirus the Hanten River there's the
West Nile virus and guinea worm and
Rocky Mountain spotted fever and of
course the Spanish flu MERS stands for
Middle Eastern respiratory syndrome it's
plastered all over airports and no one
blogs about it so why should China get a
pass congressman ted Lieu tweeted the
virus is not constrained by country or
race be just as stupid to call it the
Milan virus no that would be way
stupider because it didn't come from
along and if it did I guarantee we'd be
calling it the Milan virus
jesus-fuckin'-christ can't we even have
a pandemic without getting offended when
they named Lyme disease after a town in
Connecticut the locals didn't get all
ticked off ticked off seriously
it scares me that there are people out
there who would rather die from the
virus than call it by the wrong name
this isn't about vilifying a culture
this is about facts it's about life and
death we're barely four months into this
pandemic and the wet markets in China
the ones where exotic animals are sold
and consumed are already starting to
reopen the PC police say it's racist to
attack any cultural practice that's
different than our own
I say liberalism lost its way when it
started thinking like that and pretended
that forcing a woman to wear this was
just a different way instead of an
abhorrent human rights violation it's
not racist to point out that eating bats
is batshit crazy in 2007 researchers
at the University of Hong Kong wrote the
presence of a large reservoir saw of
SARS CoV like viruses in horseshoe bats
together with the culture of eating
exotic animals in southern China is a
time bomb
doctor foul Qi says we should force a
global closure of the wet markets
because the current crisis is a quote
direct result of them on Monday the UN's
acting head of biodiversity said the
same thing so when someone says what if
people hear Chinese virus and blame
China
the answer is we should blame China not
Chinese Americans but we can't stop
telling the truth because racists get
the wrong idea there are always going to
be idiots out there who want to indulge
their prejudices but this is an
emergency don't we have bigger tainted
fish to fry Jesus if the Sun was
exploding Twitter would pile on the
first guy who called it a dwarf star
sorry Americans were going to have to
ask you to keep two ideas in your head
at the same time this has nothing to do
with Asian Americans and it has
everything to do with China we can't
afford the luxury anymore of nonjudging
as' towards a country with habits that
kill millions of people everywhere
because this isn't the first time SARS
came from China and the bird flu and the
Hong Kong flu the Asian flu viruses come
from China like shortstop's come from
the Dominican Republic if they were
selling nuclear suitcases at these wet
markets would we be so non-judgmental
and isn't this pretty close to what they
are selling and the next one could be
even worse if the Chinese military had
purposefully infected this country with
Corona as a bioweapon we'd be at war
with them we're always griping about how
China manipulates their currency well
I'm no monetary expert but I think you
would agree this one hurt our economy a
little more than the car
wincing manipulation and China can do
this China once built a 57 storey
skyscraper in nineteen days there's been
a pothole on my street for nineteen
years they're not like us they can
actually get you it done this is a
dictatorship that for decades enforced a
one child per family policy under
penalty of forced sterilization but you
can't close down the farmers market from
hell they need to use that iron fist and
pound it down like the whole world
depends on it because it kind of does
and I hope that if someone told
Americans that eating hot pockets could
cause a worldwide pandemic that we would
have the good sense to stop doing it
although I wouldn't bet on it
you